Democrats endorse bankrupting churches
child abuse and abortion rights for men
at the CNN LGBT LMNOP Town Hall we
examine why Democrats are willing to
risk 100% of their electability
pandering to 4.5% of the population then
President Trump gets blunt unimpeached
at a rally in Louisiana
AOC cries literally cries over global
warming and the left tries to erase
Christopher Columbus 527 years after the
great man discovers America all that and
more I'm Michel Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
oh it is one of my favorite days not
National Coming Out Day although we'll
cover that too
it is Columbus Day oh we will celebrate
the great man as the left tries to erase
him from history but first don't let
history get a race don't let your
wonderful memories get erased give or
receive a truly meaningful gift at paint
your life calm what a segue if you have
some picture of yourself some picture of
your friend your loved one your dog a
favorite place you can have an original
painting made at a price you can afford
from paint your life calm this is a true
painting done by hand by a world-class
artist created from a favorite photo
this makes the absolute perfect gift for
birthdays and anniversaries you choose
the artist whose work you most admire on
the website and you work with them
throughout the process until every
detail is perfect and there's no risk at
all if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded I was totally
skeptical of this and so I obviously
used it to get a painting done for my
stepbrothers wedding I didn't want to
try it on myself first I tried it on him
I was so blown away with the quality of
this painting that now I'm using them so
many more times especially as Christmas
comes around it's unbelievable and you
get to pick out the artist it's just I
was really stunned and blown away so the
luckily because they work with you
throughout the process you get to see
different proofs and you get to see how
it's going so I already thought it was
pretty cool then I see it in person it
is astounding your you will get a piece
of art that you will cherish forever
makes a really special gift for someone
you love or for yourself I cannot speak
highly enough of these guys it is an
unbelievable service right now is a
limited time offer you get 30% off your
painting do it right now this is a great
gift do it for yourself and do it for a
loved one 30% off and free shipping to
get this special offer text Knolls KO
wles
2 48 48 48 that's KO wala s 2 for 8 for
8 for 8 k nowl es 2 48 48 48 message and
data rates may apply
alright so many days to cover Columbus
Day
coming out day LGBTQ town hall day on
CNN the they actually called it the
Equality Town Hall they didn't use the
accurate description which is it was a
town hall about these different sexual
identities and sexual preferences they
have to say equality and the euphemism
tells you a lot but first I did a little
math I did a little math because the
left is always trying to bring out
identity politics and different victim
groups and pander to each of these
groups so I thought okay the left does
this on the basis of race on the basis
of sex and now on the basis of sexual
and gender identity and sexual
preference so I did some math black
people who constitute 12% of the
population only get 8.3 percent of the
calendar year this is because there's
February's Black History Month women
constitute fifty point eight percent of
the population over half of the
population is women they also only get
eight point three percent of the
calendar year they get Women's History
Month which is in March LGBTQ on and on
and on people who constitute at most
four and a half percent of the
population that's the current estimate
get sixteen point seven percent of the
calendar because they get Pride Month
which is in June and they get October
which is LGBTQ History Month declared so
by Barack Obama with National Coming Out
Day in all these different sexual days
how does that work how did the Left
decide that they were going to pander to
black people for less of the calendar
year than they constituted the
population that they were gonna pander
to women way less of the calendar year
than they are by population or than they
would deserve by population and that
they are going to pander to this
relatively small and also very very
diverse sexual identity group for a
hugely disproportionate amount of time
well not only it was a hugely
disproportionate amount of time in the
calendar year was a hugely
disproportionate amount of time on the
CNN Town Hall I cannot believe that I
watched this whole thing I had very
prominent people in the news
media and in conservative politics
messaging me thanking me for watching
the four and a half hour
LGBTQ townhall on CNN so that they
didn't have to just occurred to me that
the number of hours of the townhall
corresponds to the percent of the
population that identifies as LGBTQ so
they called it the Equality townhall
that is a euphemism what does he mean
equality that could be any townhall you
could be talking about mathematics you
could be talking about political rights
you could be talking I guess about
sexual identity but that wouldn't be at
the top of the list the euphemism is the
key people use euphemisms when they are
trying to conceal the truth this is what
political correctness is this is what so
much of the Trump era has been about
revealing and it's what we talk about on
this show a lot you use euphemisms to
conceal the truth now sometimes you do
it out of politeness so when you see an
old woman you don't call her an old
woman you call her a woman of a certain
age and that's the sort of polite
euphemism so that you don't sound like
you're insulting somebody sometimes it's
not about politeness sometimes the
deception is much more nefarious so
you'll say undocumented Americans
instead of illegal alien
why do you say undocumented Americans
you don't say it to be polite to
somebody because usually you're not
using it in a personal context you're
using it in a public debate and you use
that euphemism where the left wants you
to use that euphemism so that they win
the debate before the debates already
begun because if you have a debate over
what should we do about illegal aliens
then it's pretty clear well they're
breaking the law they're aliens which
means they're foreign nationals so I
guess we should probably take them out
of our country and bring them back to
the countries that they're citizens up
but if you start your debate not using
that accurate and clinical term but you
use this euphemism undocumented America
what should we do about undocumented
Americans well they're Americans after
all I guess I guess they're certainly
gonna stay here we're not going to
deport Americans well are they Americans
they don't they're not citizens they
don't yeah well they're not citizens
because they don't have any documents
it's not because they're actually not
citizens but they just don't have
documents they're undocumented so that's
a problem we gotta get them documents
they're undocumented Americans the way
to fix that is to get them
and so you subvert the debate before
it's even begun the debate over gay
marriage to use a more relevant example
the debate over gay marriage what it
really is what is marriage what is
marriage define marriage for me describe
marriage
well the left would say it's a loving
bond between two people I have a loving
bond with members of my family am i
married to my family no I have a loving
bond with my best friend or he and I'm
married no well it's a even if you don't
think so it's a loving bond between two
people okay I have a loving bond between
three people and actually in romantic
love these days there are a lot of
Americans have a loving bond between
multiple people at the same time when
you look at surveys of polyamory you've
got four to five percent of people
identifies polyamorous why is why is
marriage a loving bond only between two
people and okay so then they'll go on
and I'll try to whittle it down and
explain finally the traditional answer
would be sexual difference men and women
sexual difference is essential to
marriage it always has been sex
specifically sex open to the possibility
of life is essential to marriage and
then you could have that debate that
would be what that debate looks like but
that's not what the left did what the
left did is they began with the premise
that marriage is a monogamous bond
between two people of any sex
why monogamous because they just
arbitrarily said so why is that the
definition because they began with that
premise and then the debate became over
marriage equality who has the right to
get married well if it's just about
rights and equality obviously we want
everybody to be equal a via Slee we want
everybody to have rights
they won the debate before it began
because they didn't have the debate they
just started with their own conclusion
as the premise even the the group that
pushed gay marriage or the redefinition
of marriage it's called the human rights
campaign when I think of human rights
I think of political Liberty I think of
freedom from tyranny I think of security
in your own body and your own property I
mean there's so more liberal definition
of human rights we think water food
redefining marriage in a way that has
not been
true for ever anywhere in the world that
probably is pretty low in the list of
human rights but by naming their
organization the Human Rights Campaign
who's going to oppose human rights
obviously nobody so that's what you see
here the Equality Town Hall what the
Equality Town Hall blew up for us is
this idea this lie that the whole
premise of this movement to redefine
marriage to redefine sex is the whole
premise was it's a personal matter it
doesn't affect you what's it to you
how dare you it's not affecting your
life and it's none of your business
Elizabeth Warren started out embracing
this view in the debate when she was
asked about same-sex marriage she was
asked in the debate what do you say to
people who still abide by the definition
of marriage that has existed everywhere
for all of human history instead of the
new definition of marriage which
includes same-sex unions her answer is
if you don't want a same-sex marriage
don't get one but then listen to the
little barb that comes in at the end of
it let's say you're on the campaign
trail and you're approached and a
supporter approaches you and says
senator I'm old-fashioned and my faith
teaches me that marriage is between one
man and one woman what is your response
well I'm gonna assume it's a guy who
said that and I'm gonna save them just
marry one woman
assuming you can find one yeah you tell
him Liz yeah those idiots who believe
the thing that every human has always
believed everywhere those guys are
idiots and they're unattractive and
they're terrible and they could never
find a spouse and they're probably men
and men are bad and women are good and
straight people are bad but gay people
are good or something I don't know it's
just so the whole Town Hall was just
absolutely shocking pandering but you
see there
Liz Warren being probably the most
cautious candidate of any of them right
now is still playing in that realm of
look live-and-let-live we find out
though it's a lot more like that
McCartney song it's a lot more like Live
and Let Die baito or work brings us up
it comes right out with it when he
threatens to bankrupt churches schools
and other institutions that don't buy
into LGBTQ ideology this is from your
LGBTQ plan and here's what your rights
as a quote freedom of religion is a
fundamental right but it should not be
used to discriminate do you think
religious institutions like colleges
churches charities should they lose
their tax-exempt status if they oppose
same-sex marriage yes there can be no
reward no benefit no tax break for
anyone or inst any institution any
organization in America that denies the
full human rights and a full civil
rights of every single one of us and so
as president we're going to make that a
priority and we are going to stop those
who are infringing upon the human rights
of our fellow Americans hell yes we're
gonna take away your church's bado are
you gonna take away our ar-15s hell yes
bado are you gonna take away our
churches if the churches don't want to
redefine marriage hell yes we're gonna
take it away bethe what work does this
thing that the left must hate him for
which is the conservative and social
conservative argument is always we can't
do this thing because if we do this
thing pretty soon we'll do that thing
it's the slippery slope argument and
what the left is always said there's no
way what just because we do this thing
doesn't mean we're going to do that
thing just because we redefined marriage
doesn't mean we're going to read
find what it means to be a man and a
woman then of course they do it anyway
but they at least pretend they're not
going to bado is different
you tell bade oh if we do this thing we
can't do it because then pretty soon
we'll be doing that thing and he says
he'll yes we're gonna do that thing and
I'm gonna take away your churches and
your guns do so he that's what he does
he begins in his definition by defining
this very new very narrow conception of
marriage is a human right but he doesn't
explain why polygamy is illegal in the
United States
some people are polyamorous the same
number of people are polyamorous as the
number of people who identify as LGBTQ
so are we denying people their human
rights in this country by not allowing
polygamous marriage that's the argument
it's the exact same argument and what I
suspect is the vast majority of people
even those who support the redefinition
of marriage would say no it's fine to
exclude polygamy from the definition of
marriage
you're talking about the same exact
percentage of people you're talking
about the same sort of radicalism in
redefining marriage in fact in some ways
less radicalism because at least in
polygamy you can still have sexual
difference
why is one a necessary important human
right where if you oppose it you're a
bigot and the other one is just totally
crazy try to answer that question if you
can't answer that question maybe there's
been a flaw in your logic earlier on
Booker went even further he said non
tax-exempt organizations would face
consequences to not just churches and
religious schools but even non
tax-exempt organizations that don't
totally celebrate redefining marriage or
any other aspect of LGBTQ ideology would
would face consequences then you get
into the craziest pandering a ball which
is the first two guys to go up on this
stage actually just started flirting
with men in the audience because there's
such slimy politicians that they thought
well I'm at the gate town hall I guess I
should probably flirt with some men yeah
that'll win over all the gay votes so
Booker comes up there and he starts
talking about what a beautiful man there
there is in the audience because he and
Booker are both bald guys one of the
most handsome haircut
I was about to say the same
all right you are a beautiful man all
right many people have no idea that
Baker president bald again yes all right
not only his Booker bad at flirting he's
obviously very awkward he also doesn't
know when to end a joke so you'd like
just a little advice for Cory Booker
when you tell a joke and you get a laugh
move on some people that they tell a
joke they get a laugh and they want to
just wring it dry
trying to make a meal out of a cupcake
come on senator then Joe Biden decides
at one point he's nearly going to kiss
Anderson Cooper while he describes how
Barack Obama kissed him I went in on
Monday and all the national press saying
Biden is gonna really get nailed when he
walks into sees the president read
morning puff he got up and he walked
over to me said well you told me he gave
me a kiss I swear to God
okay fortunately we didn't hear a story
about Barack Obama nailing Joe Biden but
we did hear about Barack Obama kissing
Joe Biden Biden then almost kisses
Anderson Cooper this was after he
flirted with an audience member said
that the guy looked like he was walking
out of GQ and he said during the debate
he's that when I came out and then he he
waited a moment and then people
applauded so he nearly came out of the
closet on the debate the pandering then
reached a tipping point when Cory Booker
decided to blame a very infamous Islamic
terrorist attack on right-wing
conservatives on June 12th 2016 I was
president as a man with an assault
weapon murdered 49 mostly LGBTQ people
of color at pulse nightclub I was very
lucky to make it out unfortunately my
friends were not that night we were
reminded that LGBTQ people specifically
those of color are often too often the
targets of hate violence with the rise
of violence against trans women of color
how will you ensure that law enforcement
is equipped to treat marginalized
victims of crime with dignity and
respect
so first of all very clearly it is some
national emergency the majority of
terrorist attacks in this country since
9/11 have been right-wing extremist
groups the majority of them have been
white supremacists in hate groups yeah
that's the point we're talking about an
Islamic terrorist attack at pulse
nightclub in Orlando where during the
shooting the Islamist shooter pledged
allegiance to Isis so that's why it's so
urgent it's a national emergency we need
to condemn white supremacists and
right-wingers because an Islamist shot
up a gay nightclub his point obviously
what a stupid response but his point
that he's trying to make is that white
supremacist terror is a far greater
problem in America than Islamic terror
and this claim we hear this claim a lot
by the left it is not backed up by the
facts at all so to make this point what
the left always does is they begin with
since 9/11 dot-dot-dot all of these
terrorist attacks seems like they're
sort of cheating a little bit there when
you say since the largest terrorist
attack in American history which was
carried out by a whole group of Islamic
terrorists and directed by Osama bin
Laden taking that aside other than Pearl
Harbor what if the Japanese ever done to
us okay I mean that's kind of a big one
you're kind of leaving out the big one
let's say though let's just for the sake
of a thought experiment let's use their
own numbers let's use their own premises
so we're gonna take 9/11 off the table
even using their own numbers the numbers
don't tell the story that the left think
they do here's a 20-17 study by in the
investigation fund which found that
white supremacist attacks in America
outnumber Islamist attacks and foiled
attacks by a ratio of two to one guess
that's a lot
twice as many attacks and plots by white
supremacists as by Islamists but there
are way way way more
white people in America than Muslims so
sixty point seven percent of America is
white 1.1 percent of America is Muslim
white people outnumber Muslims in
America by a ratio of 55 to one so if
white supremacist plots outnumber
Islamist plots by by a ratio of two to
one that still shows a hugely shockingly
disproportionate number of Islamist
plots so if you're trying to identify a
problem with hugely disproportionate
numbers that would be the problem to
identify but Booker and the left they
have no interest in identifying the
problem they have certainly no interest
in solving the problem all they have to
do is twist every single argument every
single question to attack conservatives
right-wingers or I mean they may view
white and conservative to be synonymous
obviously that is not the case but
that's how they view it so to attack
everybody at the top of the
intersectional pyramid white straight
people who are the same sex that they
think that they are male rather than
female a ridiculous point but a good
opportunity Booker gives us a good
opportunity to debunk a major talking
point of the left then we get to really
the most disturbing issue of the whole
Town Hall which is the first question of
the Town Hall begins with Cory Booker a
woman comes up and says I'm the mother
of a nine year old transgender child so
from the very beginning there's just a
woman asking this question but from the
very beginning this CNN Town Hall is
normalizing child abuse if a mother is
foisting gender ideology on her child a
child who's in the single-digit age
range that mother is committing child
abuse that is some horrific stuff if you
tell your little boy that he's really a
little girl because he picked up a
Barbie one time and you confuse him
sexually in a truly damaging life
enduring sort of way you are committing
child abuse that's how the thing begins
I think okay we're really through the
looking-glass now this woman might have
introduced herself as a sufferer of
Munchausen by proxy as someone who who
seeks attention by pretending to care
the people that she cares a better ill I
thought this would be the most
craved aspect of the night my
expectations were too loved because he
got so much worse a woman then brought
her daughter on stage and presented her
daughter as a nine year old transgender
America I don't even well I'm not gonna
play the clip I had the collide pulled
the clip and I could play the clip but I
don't want to participate in the abuse
of this child so I'm not gonna play it
the little girl comes on stage and she's
dressed in a suit and she says I'm a
nine-year-old transgender American and
my name is Joseph or Jacob or something
like that roaring applause from the
audience I'm sure the moderators and the
people backstage we're doing it to the
CNN producers and everyone else who
exploited this child or monsters and
this sort of child abuse should be
criminal and the perpetrators should
face the stiffest possible consequences
that's during the debate during a major
presidential Town Hall on CNN the big
leftist cable network what this means to
me is the arguments against Trump are
pretty weak I get the arguments against
Trump we're gonna get into one of the
arguments against Trump in a second I
understand them all look I worked for a
competitor of his in the 2016 primary I
did TV commercials for Ted Cruz okay
it's not like I was immediately from the
very beginning this big Trump guy in the
face of this LGBTQ town whole there is
no argument there is no argument because
from mean tweets because he did
something in Syria that you don't like
for a war that we don't even know what
we're doing there because he lowered
taxes and picked a judge that you don't
like what is the argument you've got
people on stage with a Democrat media
leftist apparatus abusing a child on
national television
you've got the major presidential
candidates saying they're going to
defund churches bankrupt churches if not
outlaw them all together
you've got presidential candidates
saying even if you're not tax-exempt
you're gonna face consequences if you
don't
radically redefine marriage all of these
people on stage and and you're gonna
pick one of them
or you're gonna not vote at all and let
one of them win because Trump did what
he had a phone call with Ukraine give me
a break people I didn't even get to the
most ridiculous part of the whole debate
the most ridiculous part is that the
whoo-hoo Leon Castro who's not gonna be
in the race for much longer but he's
still in it now who Leon Castro had said
at an earlier debate that he supports
abortion not just for women but for
trans women he said this because he
didn't know what trans women means trans
women means men who dress up like women
they have male biology they cannot have
a baby they certainly can't have an
abortion
so I joked on Twitter said I wonder if
Julio Castro is gonna double down on his
support of abortion for men because
we're through the looking-glass his
national political director responds to
my joke and says quote of course to
anyone who needs an abortion however
they identify hashtag equality town hall
that will miss Natalie Montelongo in the
face of this we see the moral error of
opposition of conservative opposition to
Trump Trump has many faults the
alternative is shutting down churches
killing babies and pumping kids who
survive abortion full of hormones and
puberty blockers I don't see very much
argument for voting against Trump
anymore doesn't mean I don't want to
criticize Trump I'm about to criticize
Trump right now and there's a particular
reason that I need to criticize Trump
because he really irritated me at the
Louisiana Town Hall but politics is
about context politics is about
gradations and and priorities in the
face of that sort of insane radicalism
on the left I don't see a whole lot of
argument for abstaining the stakes are
just too high we will get to my
criticism now as president Trump we will
get to AOC crying over global warming
and we will get to the man Christopher
Columbus one of the greatest men who
ever lived
we'll get to all them in a second first
another Kingdom fans season 3 episode 3
is dropping today check that out it's
gonna be a lot of fun
a new episode will drop every Monday for
the duration of the show subscribers get
early access to those episodes on Friday
so do not wait subscribe now also
subscribers exclusively can catch up on
past seasons now at daily wired.com so
get ready for the final season of
another Kingdom today when you subscribe
to the daily water ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you get the in proclaim and sure you get
the Ben Shapiro show you get another
Kingdom you get them out well sure you
get to ask questions and a mailbag
coming up on Thursday you get everything
and you get the leftist ears tumblr you
are going to need that leftist ears
tumblr because the left shot a lot of
their credibility away with some of
their crazy answers at the LGBT Q
townhall make sure you get the tumblr or
you will drown daily wire comm we'll be
right back with a lot more
during the insane townhall on CNN
President Trump was holding a rally in
Louisiana and the rally was pretty good
he got his base all fired up it was very
entertaining as always he did something
that irritates me so much and I will
admit I know it seems like a
disproportionate reaction to a minor
slight president Trump he went blue he
went blue he used Volger language in
public here as president Trump
describing the prospect of impeachment
the Radical Democrats policies are crazy
their politicians are corrupt their
candidates are terrible and they know
they can't win an election day so
they're pursuing an illegal invalid and
unconstitutional both impeachment there
it is I hate it I hate it when President
Trump uses foul language in public what
he said was absolutely true every word
of it he said was true
what his use of the word BS absolutely
justified if I were sitting around a bar
I'd use exactly the same word and it
would be just as accurate then as when
President Trump is speaking publicly the
president should not use foul language
in public it is degrading I know Mike
toughen up Michael it's a come on it's a
minor point no politics is speech
politics is speech we've known this
since the Ancients since the ancient
Greeks the thing that separates politics
from just me and you clubbing at each
other over the head is that we have our
capacity of speech which uses symbols to
express what were you doing in our
faculties of reason to persuade one
another of how we should live and how we
should govern ourselves when you use
foul and stupid language you degrade
yourself you degrade it what is the
representation of your humanity now we
all do it sometimes we do it for comedic
effect we do it for emphasis
some people use swear words like commas
that's probably not the best thing to do
we do it I do it too
I try not to swear as much because it it
doesn't make you sound very clear it
doesn't make you sound very in control
of yourself and I really try not to do
it in public because it's disrespectful
it's disrespectful to people who don't
want to hear that kind of thing it's
disrespectful to the office of the
president which should be higher up it
should embody the ethos and the spirit
of the country and there's always been a
little bit of vulgarity to the spirit of
America so I totally understand it I
hate it I just don't like it and
President Trump should try to minimize
it he can make his point
just as forcefully without doing it and
it wouldn't he is no reason to degrade
himself Trump has more integrity and a
little finger than the left has in their
entire apparatus the left kills babies
is foisting gender ideology on
three-year-olds and wants to bankrupt
your church they have no credibility and
no integrity whatsoever
Trump has actually kept more of his
campaign promises than any president in
my lifetime he actually does have
integrity when he does stuff like that
though he goes blue in public he really
cuts against that argument that's my
minor criticism of President Trump for
the day much crazier in the world of
rhetoric was AOC who was giving a speech
about global warming and decided to get
misty-eyed to start crying because she's
convinced the world is about to end and
she now feels that she can't be a mother
I speak to you not as an elected
official or public figure but I speak to
you as a human being a woman whose
dreams of motherhood now taste
bittersweet because of what I know about
our children's future and that our
actions are responsible for bringing
their most dire possibilities into focus
I speak to you as a daughter and
descendants of colonized peoples who
have already begun to suffer what is she
suffering
last I checked she's getting $300
haircuts and living in a posh apartment
in Washington DC and going on television
all the time what is she suffering she
said I am suffering I am a member of an
indigenous peoples group that and we are
suffering what what are you suffering
what are what are other people suffering
there is no evidence that the world is
going to end in 12 years
there's none not one little bit not
that's not scientific it's not even I
don't know even to call it a religious
view is is not really supported by the
evidence because most religious views
have some logic to them some have a lot
of logic to them this has no logic
none whatsoever the worst predictions
the worst global warming predictions are
that the earth will warm about two
degrees over a century there is no
evidence that this will pose any problem
for humans certainly will not pose any
problems for Americans
why is aoc worried about having children
look if IOC doesn't have children I'm
not gonna look a gift horse in the mouth
exactly but in the spirit of humanity
because I am human and nothing human is
alien to me I would like a OC to feel
like she is free to have children
she said why why doesn't she want to
have children now because she says we
know that they will face the diarist of
consequences what's the diarist of
consequence death would be the diarist
of consequences a OC thinks that because
we drive automobiles that in the next
generation all the children are gonna
die and that's the diarist of
consequences and therefore she's crying
on stage right now today we kill 1
million babies a year in this country
before they're born 1 million babies
every single year we know that they face
the diarist of consequences we know
because it's happening right now we
don't know that in 10 years all the
children are gonna die actually we know
that they're not going to because
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
short of a comet a meteor hitting the
earth that's not going to happen
in a hundred years based on all of the
available evidence all the children
aren't going to die right now today 1
million of them a year or
AOC doesn't shed a tear for that OC
campaigns for it this is either the
product of a profound ignorance or
insanity and I'm actually gonna give a
OC the benefit of the doubt here I'm
gonna give her the benefit of the doubt
and say that it's ignorance because when
I was a teenager I was pro-abortion
I didn't I didn't understand the
argument for pro-life I didn't get it I
just thought well they're not babies and
I just didn't think more about that
because that's what I was told by the
media and by educational institutions
and by politicians and by everyone
around me in New York but then once you
see it you can't unsee it and it is a
baby shouldn't kill babies I'm gonna
give aoc the benefit of the debt I know
I know a lot of pro lifers have come up
to me and said Michael I just don't
understand how anyone could support
abortion I totally do Abby Johnson one
of the greatest pro-life advocates
worked at a Planned Parenthood because
she obviously didn't see the problem
with abortion dr. Bernard Nathanson was
one of the founders of the pro-abortion
movement he was the founder of nay row
the big abortion rights League now he's
one of the biggest pro-life advocates
Jane Roe Jane Roe in Roe vs. Wade is is
the reason why there's a so-called
National right to abortion in America
she then became one of the biggest
pro-life advocates in the country
obviously people can be fooled by the
illogic of abortion and then come around
and see reality so I'm going to I'm
going to assume that AOC is just
ignorant ignorant on the climate
ignorant on life ignorant on a whole lot
of things I mean she said in one of her
first interviews that she's not the
expert remember on the Hoover
Institution show uncommon knowledge not
uncommon knowledge she was on that
firing line with Margaret Hoover that is
a profound ignorance
it requires humility to fix that
ignorance unfortunately the left doesn't
have that humility and I think the way
that we conservatives can reach them is
by asking questions not but if you if
you just go straight out and attack them
all the time if you're constantly
beating that drum you're probably not
going to change their minds you might
change other people's minds in the
audience but you're not going to change
their minds because you're you are
playing into their pride you're giving
their pride a reason to assert itself if
you ask with some humility these simple
questions like well what's your evidence
that the world's gonna end in 12 years
what's your evidence that all the
children are going to die if you're
worried that all the children are dying
what about abortion just simple
questions I think there's an easier way
to reach them there's a lot of ignorance
going around especially on the subject
of one of my favorite holidays of the
year I'm speaking of course about today
Columbus Day and the person one of the
greatest men to ever live of Christopher
Columbus Christopher Columbus much
maligned now in our in our phones when
you when you turn on your phone you will
see in different calendar apps that it
is indigenous peoples day throughout the
United States various cities have tried
to redefine Columbus Day as indigenous
peoples day Christopher Columbus is
being maligned without any basis in
reality as a mass murderer as a genocide
ulm a niak is a bad navigator as this is
this is people who can't get to the
grocery store unless they plug in their
iPhone and get type in Google Maps and
their maligning the discoverer of the
Americas because he went off course a
little bit and still discovered America
and went back several times anyway talk
about humility and talk about pride
Columbus is being wiped out of our
history books for absolutely no reason
it reminds me as always of Tony
Soprano's great moral clarity on the
subject of Christopher Columbus they
would make fine servants with 50 men we
could sub gate them subjugate and make
them do whatever we want that doesn't
sound like a slave here to deal George
Washington had slaves the father of our
country what's your point his history
teacher mr. Cushman is teaching your son
that if Columbus was alive today he
would go on trial for crimes against
humanity like Milosevic and you know
Europe your teacher said that
it's not just my teacher it's the truth
it's in my history book
so you finally read the book and it's
both Tony Oh get the book at Columbus
his shoes to see what he went through
people thought the world was flat for
crying out loud then he lets on an
island with a bunch of naked savages on
it I mean I took a lot of guts you
remember when we with the flower to the
heat and those bugs
well like it took guts to murder people
and put him in Chains he was a victim of
his time who cares it's what he did he
discovered America as what he did he was
a brave Italian explorer and this house
Christopher Columbus is a hero end of
story
you tell him Tony so why do we celebrate
Christopher Columbus because none of us
would be here with a Christopher
Columbus we had how many places in
America are named Columbus or Columbia
Columbus Ohio Columbia the country
called Columbia there's a District of
Columbia there's all manner of things in
America named after Columbus as they
should be we celebrate Columbus Day
specifically this began in 1891
now 1892 because in 1891 we had the
largest mass lynching in American
history that was of 11 Sicilian men and
so as a way to sort of apologize to the
Italian Americans in the country they
decided to celebrate this great Italian
explorer who discovered the Americas and
that was why we had in 1892 Columbus Day
400 years after Columbus is viet voyage
in 1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue
what did Columbus do at one of the
arguments against him they say is a
genocide Oh maniac he never committed
genocide whatsoever that's just based on
nothing they say he's a mass murderer
he wasn't a mass murderer John Fugelsang
who I kind of like he's that left-wing
radio guy he tweeted out he said
Columbus was one of the worst mass
murderers ever happy indigenous peoples
day how many people do you think
Columbus murdered when people ask you
this or when people tell you that
Columbus was a mass murderer ask them
give me a number
how many people did Columbus murder
50,000 60,000 50 60
102 510 they don't know they don't have
an answer for that you might ask them
this did Columbus murder more or fewer
people than the 80,000 people that the
Aztecs slaughtered in the course of four
days at the consecration of the temple
of Tenochtitlan five years before
Christopher Columbus sailed to America
it's not like the Aztecs killed them
three thousand years earlier five years
1487
the Aztecs slew eighty to eighty four
thousand people in the course of four
days at the consecration of the temple
of Tenochtitlan well Michael that's
different how's it different you're
saying that we can't celebrate
Christopher Columbus because he I guess
became his governor of the Indies so he
was involved in the deaths of some
people but you want to replace Columbus
day with indigenous peoples day the
Aztecs are pretty good representatives
of indigenous peoples right they are
indigenous peoples they slew eighty
thousand people in the course of four
days so if you're gonna get rid of
Columbus Day I guess you got to get rid
of indigenous peoples day but Michael
it's not fair to judge people by their
very worst qualities everybody's flawed
and has bad qualities Oh hmm good point
all right then let's go back to Columbus
day because Christopher Columbus is one
of the greatest most virtuous men who's
ever lived the guy was a man of low
birth he more or less taught himself
everything he was Italian he learned to
read Latin he learned to speak and write
Spanish he was one of the great
travelers he went to Iceland he went to
Africa he went all over the place as a
navigator he then he was so consumed
with Christianity was so devoted a
Christian that he went he at the time
when many people did not read the Bible
he read the Bible with monks he was in
the Azores he was convinced that he had
to go and discover this this trade route
to the Indies he went he asked a ton of
different grounds to fund it he went to
Portugal when that didn't work he set up
an incredible pitch in Spain he goes to
Spain they still wouldn't give it to him
he walks out of the court and one of
Isabella's messengers came and ran and
got him turned him around and said he
was the the man for the job and it was
through his own tenacity and
determination he then set sail and
against all odds makes it to this new
world obviously not to the East Indies
but to the West Indies he makes it there
he's the the first man in this Western
experience of encountering native in
primitive peoples and obviously the the
first time that Europe is going to
engage in colonialism is going to have
some victims there's no question nobody
is denying that and yet what they accuse
him of is being especially cruel toward
the Spanish the historical records is
exactly the opposite
even Bartolome de las casas what the one
of the greatest defenders in history of
the native people said that Christopher
Columbus was personally quite merciful
toward the natives
when the Spaniards that Columbus
travelled with wanted to hack up all of
the natives for minor offenses
Christopher Columbus weighed in on their
behalf weighed in in their defense
Christopher Columbus when a friend of
his a native friend died he adopted his
own son raised him as his own son the
the main argument against Columbus is
based on one document and it was a
document written to the crown in Spain
by a man named Francisco de Bobadilla
who was Columbus's chief political rival
in the West Indies
and usurped power in the West Indies
from him this would be like saying that
if all we knew about Donald Trump if the
only negative stuff we knew against
Trump came from Hillary Clinton and we
said well because Hillary Clinton said
the Trump is a bad guy therefore it is
completely clear the Trump is a bad guy
that's or vice versa by the way if the
only thing we knew negatively about
Hillary Clinton is what Donald Trump
said you couldn't rely on that either
because they were political rivals he
was it was brought back even in Chains
to the crown why did the crown believe
Bobadilla in part because then the crown
didn't have to pay Columbus what it owed
him in Columbus still persevered
Columbus still continued he went back
and forth to the West Indies even more
important than that and this man I mean
not not enough could possibly be said
about this man's virtues and great great
qualities but even more than that is the
humility that we need
without Christopher Columbus none of us
would be here if you think that it's
unjust that we are here right now
you should leave go back go you don't
have to be here we have airplanes and
very cheap travel if you think that it's
awful that people inhabit the Americas
who are not the direct descendants of
Aztecs or somebody fine
go away something tells me you don't
believe that if you think that it's not
a major net positive for the world that
America exists I guess that's fine
that's your prerogative you're wrong but
just go and leave Christopher Columbus
beyond his great characteristics is one
of the central figures in history
without Christopher Columbus there would
be no such thing as Latinos what is that
what is the Latino race is the encounter
of Native Americans with Spaniards from
Europe creates Latinos even taking out
the question of his Columbus a good guy
or a bad guy the evidence is
overwhelmingly that he's a great guy
even taking men aside he's one of the
central figures in history our history
would be unrecognizable without him we
are here today because of men like
Christopher Columbus and Columbus
himself we have no right to look down
and spit on that man our life is made
possible because of what that guy did we
are standing on the shoulders of giants
and some people these historical
revisionists think that we're flying
what have those revisionists ever done
one of the people who cast aspersions on
Columbus ever accomplished they have not
accomplished one one zillionth of what
that man did they have not done one one
zillions of the good for the world that
that man did that is a question of pride
that is a question of ignorance and
hopefully in our culture we can rectify
both that's our show on Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show I'll
see you tomorrow
happy Columbus Day
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you